okay hi mariposa global my name is jose
de Ferreira I'm a technology pioneer
here in Davos and for my company Newton
it's a national online education company
adaptive learning cloud-based stuff
personalizing education for everyone and
so you asked about how you increase
educational opportunity so we don't
waste human resources while still
maintaining excellence in education and
it's that's an awesome question so I
guess the short answer is the problem is
probably even bigger than you know
because eighty percent 80 percent of the
world's schoolchildren lack access to
basic education but really basic like
they can barely read or write they can't
really do basic arithmetic money so
that's just the kind of the primary
secondary level and that you know once
you get to college university obviously
the numbers are much lower than that so
we really have to massively increase
capacity in the global education system
and so like your question how do you do
that while while maintaining standards
of excellence and I think the answer is
going to be technology-based which is
where I sort of my company its
technology combined but I think online
education digital distribution of
education is going to revolutionize
education than explains 10 years and
dramatically increase capacity of the
system which means dramatically increase
opportunities for people around the
world you know you can buy every kid in
Nigeria the most populous nation in
Africa an ipad for three or four million
dollars today so imagine in five or ten
years when you've got next gen eBook
readers you know laptops it's much
cheaper to give everyone those then
let's build an enormous infrastructure
of education nationally so developing
world countries can least begin to have
a blended solution of bricks and water
education supplemented with with online
education so you can get every kid in
the world access to the world's best
teachers all of a sudden whether it's
archived video or even live video
classes on a mobile device like a laptop
or an e-book reader and education
technology is improving very quickly at
the same time so not only can you
increase distribution but companies like
Newton will make it very personalized
every student literally gets a unique
textbook every morning personalized for
them at the atomic concept level based
on exactly what they know and how they
learn best so for instance this is what
my company does we power textbooks keep
our courses and we know things like you
learn math best in the morning you learn
geometry fest at 830am or between 8 30
and nine twenty am you learn cell
division concepts and no more than 14
minute increments where you learn UN
history concepts best with to include
video clips or the combination of text
and video and so on and so forth so that
kind of highly personalized experience
which is never existed in education
before is just around the corner thanks
very much